we demand a lot of our databases and our
databases demand a lot of us they're
fragile expenses and tough to maintain
when things break it can be hard to put
the pieces back together at the speed of
your business and you often lose data in
the process we've all come to expect the
distributed databases can't be globally
consistent and scalable but what if you
didn't have to make trade-offs what if
you could have a fully managed database
service that's consistent scales
horizontally across data centers and
speak sequel this is clouds banner a
mission-critical relational database
service built from the ground up and
battle-tested at Google for strong
consistency and high availability at
global scale at Google we use spanner
for services that billions of people
access every day it's the only cloud
service designed to be a massively
distributed relational database with
transactions and sequel semantics and
we're talking massive planner can scale
up to millions of machines across
hundreds of data centers and trillions
of database rows stretches across the
globe while behaving with it all in one
place
where you want it we've built cloud
spanner to be fully managed in secure
automatic sharding and synchronous
replication with low latency and schema
updates without downtime means your data
is highly available and reliable instead
of endless provisioning and worrying
about maintenance you can focus on
growing your business no matter your
needs you don't have to hit a wall with
your database service get started with
cloud spanner and build what's next
[Music]